yeah james hamilton has found that
nicola sturgeon did
not breach the ministerial code he
looked at
a number of accusations that she did and
i'll just give you some of them
sarah whether the first minister
attempted to influence the conduct
of an investigation into alex almond
whether she broke the code by
continuing with the judicial review the
challenge that he lost
that that he launched whether she misled
parliament
about meetings with alex almond and
whether
she her meeting with jeff aberdeen alex
allman's former chief of staff
and meetings and phone calls she had
with mr salmond
constituted a breach of the ministerial
court
on all those counts and all these
accusations
he has said that she
did not the first minister has issued a
statement within the past couple of
minutes i'll
just read the top of that to you um
she says i welcome the conclusions of
james hamilton's independent
investigation which are comprehensive
evidence-based and unequivocal she says
he's considered all the allegations
against me i'm happy
that his reports findings clear me of
any breach
of the ministerial code today i want
once again to remind people
at the heart of this case where women
who have the courage to come forward and
complain
the first minister goes on that they
were let down by the scottish
government's handling of their
complaints
is not in dispute and i again apologize
to them for that so there you go nicola
sturgeon
pleased with finding clearly she will be
relieved
because her career hung on it had she
been found guilty of breaching
the ministerial code knowingly then
that would have been a matter in the
view of her opponent certainly for
resignation
but the breaking news right now is that
james hamilton
who's been looking into what would have
been a very serious matter her role that
no
she didn't break the ministerial code
what at the timing of this
uh james just before the start of the
hollywood election campaign
yeah well that clearly is hanging over
uh
all of this may the sixth is the the
scottish election this is the last week
the last
functioning week of the scottish
parliament
and nicolas sturgeon you know she would
have faced a degree of pressure not just
this week but
no doubt it would have hung over into
the election campaign
and it would have laid down one of the
central themes
uh of that campaign you know a first
minister in the eyes of her opponents
who had breached the code and
essentially lacked appropriate
integrity that's not been the finding of
james hamilton in this independent
review
there will be accusations the remain
calls for her resignation indeed they
will be articulated
tomorrow in the parliament chamber when
there is a motion of no confidence
brought by the scottish conservatives a
motion of no confidence in nicola
sturgeon
now had this report gone against her
that would have been troublesome because
the greens who currently are standing by
the snp
and the first minister on this matter
and she needs their votes to
to vote down any no confidence motion so
they've got the greens in the bag at the
moment had that been a critical report
the greens might have had second
thoughts and then she would have been
in trouble in terms of the numbers in
that no-conference vote
as things stand uh one imagines the
greens will
stand firm with the snp so there's every
chance that she will survive
that vote of no confidence ever likely
that she will survive
um unscathed but you know whether or not
there is damage and continuing
fallout from this i suppose we'll wait
and see but
um she and her government certainly see
her as being
in the clear and it's fair to say that
she's been cleared by james hamilton
in in this report